wer die kollegen kollegen die letzten
wochen haben uns vor augen geführt dass
in teilen unserer bevölkerung
verunsicherung wächst und dass sich die
gesellschaft spaltet und das fordert uns
als gewählte repräsentanten
unterschiedliche interessen lebensstil
meinungen
sie gehören zu jeder freiheitlichen
ordnung und um sie auszugleichen und um
zu entscheidungen zu kommen braucht es
öffentliche debatten und dazu gehören
auch demonstrationen aber die
entscheidungen müssen demokratisch
legitimiert und nicht auf der straße
gefunden werden
die ereignisse in chemnitz zwingen uns
zu unterscheiden zwischen den
unentschuldbaren gewaltexzessen und den
sorgen die viele bürger umtreiben
vor drei jahren habe ich angesichts des
großen zustroms von flüchtlingen und
migranten aus der süd und süd östlichen
nachbarschaft europas gesagt dass mir
das wie ein runde womit der
globalisierung vorkomme und heute
scheint mir dass wir erst jetzt so
richtig erkennen welche auswirkungen das
auf den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
in unserem land hat manche bürger finden
sich ihre empfindungen und wahrnehmungen
in unseren politischen und medial
vermittelten debatten nicht wieder
das aber ist eine voraussetzung dafür
dass wir die vielen atemberaubend
schnell und grundlegend erscheinenden
veränderungen für alle erträglich
gestalten gewaltfrei und im respekt vor
unterschiedlichen meinungen und
betroffenheiten menschen die sich vor zu
vielen und zu schnellen veränderungen in
ihrer lebens und erfahrungswelt fürchten
auch vor zu viel zuwanderung in kurzer
zeit solche menschen müssen genauso
ernst genommen werden wie jene die in
einer enger wachsen zusammenwachsenden
welt für offenheit
und für globale solidarität eintreten
nur der ausgleich untereinander der zu
mehr akzeptanz für den unausweichlichen
gesellschaftlichen wandel führen einer
akzeptanz die für die stabilität in
unserem land unerlässlich ist
das geht nicht ohne streit aber
gewaltfrei und nach regeln die für alle
gelten und die weder offen noch
klammheimlich unterlaufen werden dürfen
missstände müssen benannt und behoben
werden
aber permanente und maßlose
skandalisierung schadet nicht jedes
fehlverhalten in behörden ist schon ein
beweis für angebliches staatsversagen
wie wir bei der untersuchung von
verfehlungen in einer außenstelle des
bundesamtes für migration und
flüchtlinge gerade wieder gesehen haben
auch nicht jede ausschreitung bei großen
menschenansammlungen bei demonstrationen
oder aus anderen anlässen diskreditiert
deswegen alle friedlichen teilnehmer
aber die gewaltfreiheit steht über allen
diskussionen und
meinungsverschiedenheiten
das gewaltmonopol des staates und die
durchsetzung des rechts sind nicht
relativiert
unsere rechtsordnung verpflichtet alle
in gesellschaft und politik auch in
behörden und sicherheitsorganen und sie
fordert zugleich respekt für diejenigen
die diesen dienst für uns leisten
wir müssen bei der durchsetzung des
rechts besser werden schnell konsequent
sichtbar
dann können uns dann können uns kinder
erspart bleiben
von bürgerkriegsähnlichen szenen bei der
eindämmung gewalttätige ausschreitungen
wie wir das beim g20-gipfel in hamburg
erleben mussten
das ist ein appell an alle
die in unserem land für
rechtsstaatlichkeit verantwortung tragen
für das funktionieren von polizei und
justiz
wenn wir gegenseitige toleranz und
respekt untereinander sichern wollen
müssen wir darauf bestehen dass gewalt
oder die aufforderung zur gewalt genauso
verboten sind
wie die verwendung von parolen und
symbolen gegen den demokratisch
rechtsstaatlichen kunst grundkonsens
unserer republik in frage stellen
ausländerfeindlichkeit
ausländerfeindlichkeit hitler größe
nazi-symbole angriffe auf jüdische
einrichtungen für all das darf es weder
nachsicht noch verständnisvolle
verharmlosung geben
und schließlich das demonstrationsrecht
ist kein freibrief für gewaltexzesse
wir haben zu oft erlebt dass friedliche
demonstrationen von gewalttätern als
schutzraum missbraucht werden
da gibt es übrigens zwischen
gewalttätigen chaoten bei linksextremen
und schlägern und naziparolen bei
rechtsextremen keinen unterschied
wie fische im wasser müssten sich die
revolutionäre bewegen hat mainz seine
anhänger gelehrt und diese freiheit
dürfen wir den feinden unserer
freiheitlichen demokratie nicht geben
und wir dürfen auch nicht zulassen dass
mehr oder weniger feinsinnig grenzen
ausgelotet und verschoben werden wir
brauchen keine revolution sondern einen
starken und toleranten rechtsstaat und
darauf müssen wir bestehen
[Applaus]